all right
all right i'm laura inger this is ingram
angle from new york city tonight
fancy nancy fails again that's the focus
of tonight's angle
nancy patricia delisandro was born march
26 1940 the daughter and sister of
democrat mayors of baltimore
now at the ripe old age of 82 she's
currently serving her 18th term in
congress wow
she first assumed her house seat 35
years ago on june 9
1987
a different lifetime in politics in the
culture
mr gorbachev
tear down this wall
nobody puts baby in a corner
[Music]
i've concluded that i will
stop being a candidate for president of
the united states
seems like yesterday well she's been
speaker since 2019 and before that from
2007 to 2011.
democrats love her though because she's
a first the first woman speaker of the
house
and no matter what her record the press
adulation it never stops
she is a canny legislator she knows how
to get things done for historic figure
but more importantly nancy pelosi runs a
very very disciplined caucus speaker
pelosi is brilliant she is a fantastic
speaker
but tonight we're here to ask what does
nancy have to show for all these years
in office when she first took over as
speaker democrats had 233 seats to the
gop's 202
well that number grew to 257 seats in
2009 that was a big majority
but by 2011 the democrats bled 40 seats
under pelosi's reign and it ushered in a
new gop majority
thank all of you god bless you and god
bless our great question
but pelosi dismissed all this she
dismissed the rise of the tea party in
2010 and after all they had rammed
through obamacare remember that on a
party-line vote under her leadership
she didn't care about the fallout
with just her dismal electoral track
record alone one would think that the
democrats would have elected abn a
speaker right anybody but nancy
certainly after the 2018 midterms but no
apparently the party at this point is
just filled with masochists
and it chose to go through the same
exercise
all over again
now plus he is best known for her brass
knuckle style politics clinging to power
by any means necessary
including the use of political threats
five years ago in response to some
internal party criticism
this was her response
when it comes to
personal ambition having fun on tv have
your fun
i love
the arena every action has a reaction i
try to say that to them every attack
provokes a massive reaction
well remember this is the same woman who
called the tea party astroturf totally
out of touch
a national review columnist put the
pelosi saga this way anyone who has led
them to four consecutive defeats
bringing their house caucus to its
lowest point in the last 90 years and
whose name has become a cudgel with
which to beat every house candidate put
forward by the democrats ought to be
astute enough to know
when it's time to go
but no
she's in her fourth year as speaker
still leading like the old
gangster-style party boss no new ideas
nothing really great to show for herself
or america except stunts
for those who wish to we will now kneel
for our moment of silence
the kenticloth perhaps was the most
embarrassing moment she threw out the
ligament too so it's so embarrassing but
no more embarrassing than her weekly
press conferences you probably miss them
but we watch them so you don't have to
or at times
she seems like a frustrated orchestra
conductor
[Music]
odd and the woman who is so publicly
pro-abortion that she's now barred from
taking communion in the catholic church
still loves invoking the children
the reconciliation bill was a
culmination of my service in congress
because it was about the children the
children the children the children my
whole mission in congress is about the
children for the children you have to be
able to take a punch
and you have to be able to throw a punch
for the children
always for the children
and let's not forget the woman who can't
remember the catechism is an expert on
faith
catholic went to church in poland and
all that so i mean i respect the views
of other people for themselves
i don't think they have any business
telling women
how they should deal with their own
reproductive freedom
then of course let's not forget how the
press loved how she tormented president
trump with two impeachments
but you have to ask at this point what
did impeaching trump
do it two times actually accomplished
after all trump is now beating biden in
a hypothetical match up
and the gop grassroots it's more
populous more america first than ever
trump's ideas and policies are a lot
more popular than those of the old guard
republicans today
meanwhile the democrats under pelosi
they've driven inflation through the
roof have given biden a total pass on
the border and have fueled a
conservative revival on issues ranging
from rising crime to trans athletes and
women's sports
we are here
to respect
the actions of the american people to
speak out against that
specifically manifested in police
brutality
trans rights are human rights
and after 18 months of joe biden with
democrat approval numbers lower than
ever pelosi's house decided to go back
to the well
by targeting trump
i was very proud of of the presentations
that were made
in terms of values don't be distracted
by politics this is serious
we cannot let america become a nation of
conspiracy theories and thug violence
the president's lie was
and is a dangerous cancer on the body
politic
so pelosi is poised to send her party
once again back into minority status but
this time in a political route that
makes 2010 look like child's play
regardless of the political cost though
pelosi believes that by moving the
country leftward it's going to be easier
to continue that trajectory once
democrats reassume power
but fancy nancy has it wrong
once this new breed of trump-inspired
republicans assume the majority they not
only reject her status quo but roll back
her ruinous policies
i hope nancy has a lot of jenny's ice
cream in that freezer she's going to
need it
she's going to be joining it in the
political deep freeze real soon
she can have the jenny's i'll take the
popcorn because this is going to be good
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else